c'est une période compliquée pour toutes
les entreprises du monde qui depuis
plusieurs semaines ont dans leur grande
majorité dû fermer leurs portes au
public n'étant pas désigné comme de
première nécessité c'est par exemple le
cas de la marque apple dans tous les
apple store dans les pays touchés par
l'épidémie de coronavirus ont dû fermer
leurs portes
un manque à gagner que le groupe
américain tente de compenser par les
ventes en ligne
mais aujourd'hui pour booster ses ventes
la marque ait décidé de maintenir la
sortie de son nouveau produit il s'agit
d'une nouvelle version low cost de son
téléphone l'iphone est ce qui devrait
sortir dans les prochains jours et être
disponible à la vente sur internet si
certains applaudissent cette sortie qui
permet de maintenir la santé économique
de la société de continuer à consommer
pour d'autres motiver les gens à acheter
en ligne des produits qui ne sont pas
essentiels à leur survie et criminel car
qui dit nouvelle sortie de téléphones
dits usines qui tournent à plein régime
et des centaines de milliers de
livraisons supplémentaires mettant un
peu plus en danger les livreurs vendu au
prix de 489 euros
ce nouveau téléphone devrait être
disponible au courant du mois d'avril à
leur appel sera un nouveau téléphone
malgré la pandémie indécent alors est ce
que vous trouvez ça indécent vous les a
mis là où autour de autour de la table
on est potes au daaka vous êtes chez
vous sophie cottes tu trouves pas ça
indécent toi non pas du tout parce qu'en
fait il va falloir faire reprendre
l'économie et l'économie ne pourra pas
reprendre sans les industries du luxe et
de la tech
donc apple y génère attaqué deux change
oui et il génère à peu près plus de 230
mille emplois en france
donc voilà ils font tourner l'économie
très bien au mieux cette saison c'est
fermé en ce moment donc c'est on est en
compliments dans cette connerie matthieu
delormeau justement il met lui même mais
tout le monde rêve de tout le monde tout
le monde rêve d'un iphone on sait qu'un
iphone ça gros ça vaut quasiment
l'iphone qui est celui qui veut
nationaux moi j'adore et c'est vraiment
le mail et là c'est vraiment le mec du
bureau des élèves
jega je sois d'iphone os la gemmi j'ai
mis toute ma bourse de dos j'ai acheté
un iphone alors oui et ça ça vaut ça
vaut le prix d'un smic donc si tu veux
c'était aberrant et l'argent qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est super bien au
contraire ils sortent un téléphone on va
dire que tout proche visuellement du
onze qui est sorti en septembre dernier
et qui est moins cher qui est enfin
accessible entre guillemets ça reste 500
euros mais qui bien sûr plus accessible
pour tout le monde
alors évidemment il fait ça pour des
raisons il anticipe la crise donc ils
font ça pour leur boîte mais pour une
fois aussi enfin en
ce confinement on va aussi permettre
quelques affaires plus atteignable pour
les gens trouvent ça bien commencé la
rencontre sur tout le corps dévêtu fille
mercy iphone alors l'iphone oui assure
michel phone enfin ils sont pas
fabriqués en france donc ça concerne pas
les insulaires ont sessions de formation
figurines il aurait pu faire quand même
un coup gens remettent leur usine de
production en chine en fabriquant des
masses en détournant leur jeu lorsque la
chaîne de fabrication fabriquer des
masques des respirateurs n'apporte pas
qu'ils sont au service de la pandémie et
pas à faire de faire du bizness pense
qu'on va schtroumpfer ya eu de bonnes la
part d'alain apparemment son mec travail
chez apple rené grands pas du tout nous
voir moi je ne trouve absolument pas
scandaleux l'illimité d'iphone parce que
qui est comme ça le monde quoi que
quelqu'un passe c'est critiquer alors il
le fait si ça continue à faire le
travail et du monde avec les mesures de
sécurité voulues et tout à fait des
exploits communes de taille il faut
calculer pour faire et l'iphone dès les
mecs là mais voilà moi je trouve pas
tarder 4 da le il ya des choses beaucoup
plus scandaleux de faire partie de la
santé je trouvais me connaissant je
comprends mon run et reprend aller après
re laissé raymond et vous baissez pour
moi c'est ma tournée on y va il ya dix
mois non mais voilà qui veut sortir
maintenant pourquoi pas ils ont le droit
c'est toujours un évènement d'habitude
yal qui a la queue devant les boutiques
est tous là ce sera pas un événement
moi ce que je trouve indécent pour ma
part c'est les cinq cents euros je
trouve que dans apple c'est la première
boîte aux mots je crois que c'est les
plus riches au monde apa prêche pas de
leur échapper je pense qu'ils auraient
pu faire un effort en diamants lorsque
les gens vont pouvoir avoir la pleine
application ios et perd des téléphones à
100 euros
le mans et nancy mathieu salissent
enrichit son plein des sens c'est vrai
alors bye bye gains d'ici mes premiers
iphone sont sortis à 500 600 euros bien
je suis intéressé répond c'est une somme
c'est une grosse et remboursables et les
normes sean ferrer dans les spams
mathieu match on sait qu'elle est sans
quoi ce qu'on demande pas le fait des
grandes marques comme c'est pas mercedes
bmw de sortir des votes
à tort parfois de voir ses duels et du
luxe et moi mais bon moi je vous dis aux
gens ont besoin d'avoir un téléphone je
vous dire mais on n'est pas obligé
d'avoir des jeunes qu'elle est folle qui
a coûté cher
oui et j'ai pris le téléphone à phil
hill à téléphone avec la batterie la
ilaha illallah paris la ilaha illa une
valise avec l'ama qui gênait le cep
moi je sais même pas de quel gemmois bon
j'ai une connerie